foreign
[Music]
here
don't drag it
it'll keep your head up
yield
you see how you drag it
do you understand what drag means your
foot's low I'm gonna hit you every time
you're gonna hit me every time
look at my foot
when I move my Center boom
I drag my foot
I move my center and you can't hit me
look how I went
just that first one
so
hey your job is to yield so you go this
is Young it's not my job to push on it
you understand
say yes and say
so to yield I have to get to the other
side of your hand
you see what you hear
I'm not here if I say on the outside of
your hand you're going to push me
so I'm countering I'm deviating my
target you see that's gonna get hit I
deviate my Target and I get to the other
side look where I am
okay do you see
not here
you'll never get there because I'll hit
you in the face
so whoa watch your circle
boom here other side other side
watch me you're watching you
one inside
[Music]
boom inside
here
outside
nope
watch that Circle
whoa start to move forward
okay don't push back on me
there you go then it's going to yield
keep your grip
boom
there you can
counter
three wheels close
counter move
when I counter
I don't heal too much
I create a new salesman here here's our
conflict easy you see
you go
I counter this conflict
do you think okay push me
do you see you see how you pushed me
you feel that
again go
push me push me push me you see that
difference
good stalemate
use my legs and your leg
then it comes around
cool
comes around
oh good don't don't go into your own
rule let's create a stalemate then it
comes around
whoops
yeah
you see the difference
own connection you see what sort of pay
attention to me not you
I go look stay there
feel watch
you see
I have your Center you see
here I don't have your Center you see
that difference
so hold okay even as I go along move
watch
you see I have a counter you see what
you think
you have to take your Center back
with
coffee Hall
there it is you see
when you go
good
Okay go again look at the difference
all right you see it just kick me in the
face
I have to create
the Tactical logic you feel it you see
oh right there you go feel it again
you see look you see you have to keep
going wrong oh there it is right there
you see and again pay attention what do
you feel watch
you see oh even on one leg I'm grounding
and projecting okay enjoy you break it
Center there do you feel that no you
break Center they don't want to come in
come back
you see get your Center in my Center
good there's the stalemate so you have
to go up
turn up there it is right there okay
let's go
yourself
they don't have your hands tight
if if your hand size up on me when I go
fast I'm going to Palm heal you in the
face
does everyone understand that okay you
can see you're taking advantage that
we're going slow we're going slow so you
can learn each other okay
but you have to not milk the drill so
that's where your hand sits okay and you
move your Center
and you get to the inside you drag in
the foot
look wait ask say this sentence is
Sensei gravity
answer the question
I am
say it again
answer the questions
there's a connection there with my
adhesion do you understand so as you
move around it's not from my grip
I move my body I maintain the connection
whoa
you see and you feel it again
it feels exactly the same as when we
were standing still okay so my hand does
not slide up you
here we are right here
okay and you try to push it into me and
you're gonna feel that same problem you
see it's right there I'll show you
you understand so it's doable
I just have to stop trying the other
stuff so go what I just want you to feel
this wait feel that pressure okay so
watch how I'm going to keep it you go
and I keep it
you feel it again it feels the exactly
the same okay then you're going to
yields
with the terms there it is
too far
let's go back relax don't do cookie at
all you don't know pokeballs don't do
what you think is okay
okay we'll get back there
stay there switch feet
okay
so you feel that relationship
say yes because I know you do get your
arm back on your Center
okay
so here you're going to yield I'll help
you
see that stay there
stay there do you feel it like it's
right there again look
you see
Are You Gonna Keep yielding more
more
good
wait feel it stop
don't yield you're gonna turn me don't
yield okay stay there keep the safe
feeling
turn the same feeling
turn it there it is right there stay
there you feel it again it's still there
you see come back round
got it right and you're gonna go up
there came off
when you come back
you're gonna feel it again
you see push you can push on me a little
you feel it you see and then you throw
all right and I yield to this
I'm not gonna go like this
you see
keep going
I'm not gonna go like this keep going
I'm not gonna go like this James
okay
and we keep that same
connection
in my body
nice I'm not I don't mean connection
like
the rest of the world needs it okay I
mean your continent field is connecting
having an earth G and it's connecting
him too
he goes boom do you feel it like yes do
you see because you're losing your face
okay then we move you move that whole
relationship yes it's still there can
you feel that okay and then at the end
of the ritual
as he throws
that's when I yield all the way
then I harmonize with the map
foreign
that's all I'm doing watch how I'm to
exaggerate my ground Factory
do you understand
okay so whom is on the back foot I'm
going to shift it to the front that now
the back foot you see and then around
I'm on the Discord over there oh
boom
[Music]
just feeling the energy turn
worry about me yet
turn
the mic on then
turn your mind on Deck
I don't need to pull them off balance
and do all this stuff just here we are
change it boom change it again
hey thank you
okay so he's he's pushing James come
here
okay
and you're you're gonna help him push
okay so I'm on that back foot that's
what I turn boom
I I know it looks like
he's not pushing right you can see right
you can feel that so I ground that turn
around
okay
got it okay okay
so oh turn him but watch might fall so I
know I'm rooting
okay
my quad is going to turn those 30
degrees
boom
here
don't be here
don't turn it over those 30 degrees
so you are rooting
you're in the quad
oh here okay then you're gonna unturn
the quad back
home
turn it back where it was then it goes
up and in and turns again at 30 degrees
don't be here don't be over
so with that
I have the inner spiral the young hand
the fire hand the heaven cheek whoa I'm
gonna bring it down to earth boom back
up in
so you want it you don't want to have
your hands do whatever
ignore your footwork nor your quad okay
ritual whoa
comes back
here
you see
there is
fire earth lemon water boom
hot
boom
it's not just in your arms and you can't
do whatever you want with your hands
hey
focusing in I got the rooting I got the
claw
okay
and I'm going to have my my handmade
dress
for causing a turn
fire blue drop boom
claw turns back
um Earth mudra up quad turns home
don't don't worry about him he's not
he's not my goal
okay the ritualist oh
there's the feeling in my body
foreign
in my bike
[Music]
why don't you get in there you can feel
the field you're going to generate the
field and then your turn
bring your awareness to the field
turning the field
feel it generate
turn it
home
thank you
all right okay
try it again